mr. Martin you have no idea
what you have unleashed
she's unlike anything we've ever faced
welcome to prodigiously
my character Nick please just caught up
in this whole world that he doesn't want
to get caught up in who he I'm the
doctor my lens is Jekyll dr. Henry
Jekyll
the central character behind all the
events of the movie is dr. Henry Jekyll
famous for being Jekyll and Hyde dr.
Jekyll operates a thing called digit and
pretty Geum essentially is an
organization that pinpoints evil and
tries to neutralize it we recognize
examine contain destroy evil they study
the mythology's and monsters the
histories of them princess I'm an actor
she's like view the vessel for the
ultimate evil it's a science for them
and what I liked about that idea was if
we're going to ground the monsters in a
reality then let's ground it in science
we like the idea that provision was
hiding in plain sight in the Natural
History Museum and that Jekyll could use
the resources of the museum to further
his own research into monsters there's a
lot to find out with Jekyll and it's not
giving too much away to say that he has
quite a clear understanding of evil it
takes a monster to defeat a monster
I love the element of mystery it's quite
dangerous and exciting let's not be
weary from a madman
you
welcome to a new world of gods and
monsters
you
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever them to some safety hidden for
2000 years
it's in the turn
it's Purdue next
the hieroglyph said she was named
Almanac chosen to be Egypt next queen
but her thirst for power led her down a
darker path one that had to be stopped
because of your actions
this ancient power has returned
[Music]
you are alive because you were chosen
sure what evil the alternator the I
don't have it should be an unimaginable
power she's using you to regain
she will not stop until she has remade
our world
into her own
stay with me okay you can't run
you can't escape
she's got plans for you
you
you